The DCEU has gone up in flames — and now,
it seems, Warner Bros. has figured out
how to kill two films with one Rock.
Dwayne Johnson spent most of the build-up to Black
Adam teasing that the hierarchy of the DC universe
was about to change — but his ambitious dreams for
the franchise have seemingly been dashed. On the
heels of Black Adam's poor reception, Shazam!
Fury of the Gods has been met with largely
negative reviews and poor box office takings.
Ironically, none other than Johnson himself could
be to blame for the DCEU's recent misfortunes,
as he allegedly meddled behind the scenes.
A report by The Wrap details
how Johnson pushed back against
Black Adam and Shazam crossing
paths on screen. Most notably,
he apparently vetoed a Black Adam post-credits
scene in which Zachary Levi's Shazam joins the
Justice Society of America. This stinger was
eventually used in Shazam! Fury of the Gods,
but The Wrap says Johnson blocked any potential
appearances from his Black Adam co-stars.
This is just the latest example of Johnson
interfering with the DCEU. Back when the
first Shazam! movie was in development, Black
Adam was set to have a key role. However,
Johnson convinced Warner Bros. to make
a standalone Black Adam film instead,
feeling it would be a disservice to
his character if Shazam! featured a
pair of origin stories. Despite the characters'
close connection to each other in the comics,
Shazam and Black Adam made their big
screen debuts separate from each other.
While some may have thought the two would meet
in a future installment, Johnson seemingly had
other ideas. He infamously strong-armed Warner
Bros. into approving a Black Adam cameo for
Henry Cavill's Superman, setting the stage for
a massive fight between those two characters.
"Black Adam… We should talk."
Throughout the Black Adam press
tour, Johnson continuously hyped
up such a confrontation. By downplaying
Black Adam's strong links to Shazam,
Johnson unwittingly hamstrung two comic book
franchises. An argument can be made that,
if he used his platform and influence to drum
up anticipation for Shazam vs. Black Adam,
these two properties could have had a
bright future — instead of being shelved.
Now, it looks like all of these characters
will likely be either taking a long hiatus,
or getting flushed from the DCU altogether
to make room for the whole slate of new
characters. This has got to come as a major blow
to Warner Bros. Discovery. The first Shazam! was
both a critical and financial success, netting a
score of 90% on Rotten Tomatoes and bringing in
$366 million on its estimated budget of just
$100 million. Meanwhile, Shazam! Fury of the
Gods debuted with $30.1 million domestically,
bringing in less than half of its hefty budget.
To complicate matters further, new heroes
like Blue Beetle are set to join the DCEU.
If The Flash and Blue Beetle do well for
Warner Bros. Discovery, it seems unlikely
that James Gunn and Peter Safran will see
any reason to bring back failed characters,
especially with so many other DCEU
heroes already on the chopping block.
Although Dwayne Johnson has long been thought to
be one of the biggest box office draws around,
his meddling with the DCEU may
have tanked a shared three-movie
franchise. What that means for
his career remains to be seen.